I'm going to show you how to explain
anything to anyone, no matter how
complex the topic is. I'm talking when
you're trying to explain technical
workflows to non-technical stakeholders,
walking a client through changes they
don't fully understand, or trying to
pitch a complex idea to your team. And
after 15 years of coaching communication
to Fortune 500 companies and millions of
people around the world, I see this one
pattern constantly. The smartest,
technically brilliant people, they tend
to struggle the most when it comes to
communicating things they know. And
look, if that's you, it's not your fault
because nobody ever taught you how to
translate what's up here to come out of
here in a clear and concise, coherent
way. So today, I'm going to teach you
how to do just that using what I call
the clear filter. And I'll walk you
through this in a second. But first, let
me explain why people feel the need to
use complex language. When I was
younger, I used to explain things in a
really, really complex way. And it
wasn't because I didn't understand the
topic. It was because I wanted to appear
smart. And by making it sound
complicated, I felt smart and that made
me feel good. For example, I used to
talk about tax with my friends. I was
studying accounting at the time. Yes, I
was fulfilling the Asian prophecy. And
my friends were studying pharmacy and
medicine, also fulfilling the Asian
prophecy. And they didn't know much
about tax. And because I felt less smart
than them, when I showed them how to do
their tax returns, I'd deliberately use
big words and acronyms to sound clever.
I'd say something like this. Based on
your accessible income and carried
forward deductions, we'll maximize your
concessional contributions and apply the
available offsets to minimize your
taxable income,
>> which is just a complicated way of
saying you earn this much and you can
claim a few things so we'll set it up so
that you don't pay more tax than you
need to. But I didn't say it like that.
I said the unnecessarily complicated
version. And I felt great saying it like
that because I knew none of my doctor
friends would get it and it made me feel
better than them. And we'd end up in
this weird situation where I was over
complicating everything to feel more
important and confident and they were
pretending to follow along because they
didn't want to seem stupid. Two people
having a conversation that's a complete
bloody waste of time. And if you do what
I do because you lack confidence or if
you just speak in a complicated way
because you don't know any better, then
let me tell you what it's going to cost
you. people won't understand you, which
then causes them to disengage. But most
professionals, you know what? They're
really good at pretending they're still
engaged when in actual reality, they've
already mentally checked out thinking
about the movie Obsession and how bloody
brilliant it is. Great movie, Curry
Barker. Well done, mate.
>> No, no, no. Don't do that. And if you
don't fix this problem, over time,
people start avoiding interactions with
you because they see you as somebody
who's confusing, overly complicated, and
way too technical to actually talk to.
You'll be stuck in that technical role
as the cog in the machine, which brings
us to the first part of the clear
filter. The C stands for calibrate.
>> Before you explain anything to anyone,
you need to first know your audience.
How much do they already know about the
topic you're about to speak on? Most
people skip this completely. If you
assume they know everything you know,
you'll speak at a level that loses them
immediately. If you assume they know
nothing, then you can come across like
you're speaking down to them. So, this
first calibrating step involves asking
qualifying questions to determine how
much your audience already knows so you
can meet them where they are. If, for
example, you're in a one-on-one
situation with someone, you might say
something like this. Before I go any
further, how familiar are you with this
topic? However, if you're preparing for
a speaking event, email the organizer
ahead of time and ask, "On a scale of
beginner to expert, where would you say
most of the audience sits with this
topic I'm going to speak on?" And if
you're opening a group session impromptu
and you had no time to prep, then ask
the group directly a question. Ask
something like this. Quick question
before I start. Raise your hand if you
have had a year's worth of experience in
this area. Okay? Uh raise your hands if
you've had two years. Okay? Now, raise
your hands if you had three years. And
sometimes if you already know you're
walking into a group of specialists, go
deep. Use the technical language. Use
the jargon. Have the in-depth
discussion. But you need to know where
they're at first. One simple question
asked up front tells you everything you
need to know. Know your audience before
you speak to your audience. The second
part is link.
Connect what they don't know to
something they already know. You do this
by using either an analogy, a metaphor,
or a simile. I want to show you what
this looks like from someone who is
extraordinary at linking, Dr. Michelle
Feller. She spent her career at NASA,
understands astrophysics at a level that
would make most people's heads spin. But
let me share with you a clip where she
takes something really complicated and
makes it easily digestible by using an
analogy.
>> The human brain is just as far away from
perceiving the way the universe really
is as a grasshopper is perceiving
quantum mechanics. Isn't it wonderful
what she just did? Even though you and I
don't have a deep understanding of
astrophysics like she does, we were
still able to understand the concept she
was sharing. Now, imagine she didn't do
that. And imagine she read something
like this to you. I mean, look at it.
Can you even get past the second
sentence? No. No. I mean, seriously, try
to read it. Try. It's crazy, huh? No one
could do it. Not me. Not you. And no,
don't you go pretending in the comment
section that you knew exactly what that
meant because none of us did. Learning
how to link the unknown to the known is
a powerful skill set. Now, let me give
you my own example. I do a lot of
corporate trainings with engineering
teams, very technical teams. And when
I'm pitching my 2-day communication
workshop to a tech company, instead of
walking through the full curriculum and
speaking in a complex way like this, on
day one, we separate vocal image from
visual image. And then we deconstruct a
vocal image into five core concepts.
First, we've got rate of speech. Then
we've got volume, tonality, pitch, and
melody. And then the strategic pausing
which combines all together into vocal
archetypes that each trigger different
listener responses. And then on day two,
we formalize the narrative structure by
breaking stories down into discrete
incidents built around peak emotion,
peak action or the key lesson learned.
And then we derive a single governing
point so the story actually holds their
attention. Yeah, that's how I used to do
it because I thought that would make me
seem like an expert. And normally when I
do this, the clients look confused and I
can literally see them disengage and
then I end up not winning the business.
Whereas what I do now is I use a simple
metaphor, music, and then I link it to
communication, which is something most
people don't usually understand fully.
Again, the linking the known to the
unknown. That's the magic. And this is
what I say now. On day one, I'm going to
teach your engineers how to play their
instrument, being their voice and their
body language. Then on day two, I'm
going to teach them how to write great
music. And that's how to structure their
ideas so that they're clear and
compelling. And if you want a more
detailed breakdown of the 2-day
syllabus, I'll send you the PDF. That's
it. Two full days of content in under 20
seconds. And every single time I watch
the person nod and then they say, "Oh,
Vin, that's exactly what my engineers
need." So learn how to use analogies,
metaphors, and simileies. Find the link
between the known and the unknown and
make it simple for people to understand.
By the way, if you want to learn how to
go deeper into frameworks like the clear
filter that I'm walking you through
right now, I put together a free 2-hour
training where I'll teach you the top
three communication frameworks I use in
professional and personal conversations
to help you speak with more structure,
clarity, and confidence so you stop
rambling and speak more coherently. Just
click the link in the description or
scan the QR code on screen to get
access. It's completely free. Let's keep
going. The next part of the filter, E,
is for envision.
Some ideas are too hard to just describe
with words alone. And when you hit one
of those, draw it literally. I mean,
draw a shape, a triangle, a circle, a
rectangle. Draw a simple diagram. And in
this example with envision, I'm going to
be a little bit cheeky here. I'm going
to combine envision with the next part
of the filter, which is a for
abstraction.
And abstraction is taking a complex idea
and boiling it down to its simplest
form. One of the questions that people
ask me all the time is they say, "Vin,
how do you actually get good at public
speaking when you're starting from
zero?" And if I was to answer that
without envisioning and abstracting,
it'd sound something like this. First,
you're unconsciously incompetent. Then
on your journey, you move to the next
point where you become consciously
incompetent. Then most people get stuck
there. However, if you continue the
journey, then you move into conscious
competence. And very few get to the
final step where they reach unconscious
competence which is a state of mastery
that once again most never get to. You
see what the problem is? When you
explain it like that, the listener's
brain has to work harder to understand
you and remember what you're talking
about. But the moment you envision it by
drawing it out as a contextual model and
you abstract it by simplifying the
language, watch what happens. So the
question is, well, what does it look
like when you're on the journey of
improving your public speaking ability?
Well, the first part of your journey,
you start here. Unconscious
incompetence. Here you simply don't know
what you don't know. And that's okay.
Everybody starts there. We all start by
not knowing anything about anything. But
then when you watch a video like this
and you subscribe to a YouTube channel
about public speaking, then you begin
the learning journey and you move to the
second phase and you move to conscious
incompetence. In other words, what this
is is now you know now what you don't
know.
For example, you now know that in order
to get rid of the ums and the rs, you
need to learn how to pause more. And the
reason you are is simply because you're
uncomfortable with silence. That's all.
Now you know how bad ums and are. You
know how bad thiller words are. Using
like, so, do you know what I mean? Using
them excessively, you now understand
destroys your clarity. Which then now
moves us to the next stage of learning,
which is conscious competence. And what
this stage essentially means is that
you're doing it, but you still have to
think about it.
here. You know, now to get rid of the
ums and the rs, you just replace it with
a pause. So, you're doing it already,
but you still have to cognitively think
about it because your brain is in
overdrive trying to replace so many
different types of behaviors. Which now
moves us to the final stage of learning,
which is unconscious competence. This is
where you reach a state of mastery. You
no longer have to think about it because
the behaviors become automatic.
So, if you go back to the pause example,
originally when you're learning it in
the conscious competence phase, the
you're doing it, but you still have to
think about it, the pauses
will still seem a little bit unnatural.
But once you get to unconscious
competence, now here, the pauses are
automatic and they come across
completely natural. Wasn't that way
easier to understand? And I know what
you're thinking, Vinn. By simplifying
the language and dumbing it down for
other people like this, doesn't it make
you seem dumb? Well, let me ask you
this. At any point in this video, while
you were learning with me, did you feel
like I didn't know what I was talking
about? Did I seem dumb? Or were you more
engaged because you were able to follow
along? Here's a trap that most experts
fall into. Experts don't realize that
there's a difference between being a
great expert and actually being a great
leader. Being a great expert means you
personally have deep knowledge on a
subject. Good for you. But if you want
to be a great leader, you have to
develop the skill of teaching. Because
great leaders create other great leaders
and they do that by passing on what they
know through the skill of teaching. And
to be a great teacher, you need to be
able to simplify your ideas, which makes
the transfer of knowledge more
effective. And that's the best part
about great leaders. They grow other
leaders. Whereas most of the time a
great expert who doesn't know how to
become a great leader, they only grow
themselves. Einstein famously said, "If
you can't explain it to a dog, then you
don't understand it." Wait, wait, wait.
Sorry, Peter. Was that the right quote?
>> No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We were having a nice day.
>> Actually, then what the quote actually
is, if you can't explain it to a
six-year-old, you don't understand it
well enough. That's the quite silly
Billy.
>> That's what it was. Nice work, Peter.
And to the last part of the filter. R
stands for repeat.
This one's simple, but never skip it. At
the end of your explanation, close the
loop. Come back to the shape of your
idea one more time. Let me show you what
I mean. And right there, my friends, is
the clear framework. First, you've got C
for calibrate. Here's where you need to
know your audience before you even
start. Ask the qualifying questions.
Then you've got L for link. connect the
unknown to something they already
understand by using an analogy, a
metaphor or a simile. Then you've got
envision. Here's where you draw it, make
it visible, use contextual models. Then
you've got abstraction. This is where
you distill the message to its simplest
form. And then are repeat what I've
literally just done to you in this
segment of the video. Being able to
simplify something is one of the most
important traits of a great communicator
and therefore a great leader. It means
you understand what you know so deeply
that you can translate it for anyone.
So, pick one complex idea this week that
you need to explain to someone and run
it through the clear filter and watch
what happens. And if you want to keep
building on what you've been learning
today, click on the link in the
description for my free 2-hour training
to learn more about communication
frameworks or just scan the QR code to
access it right